hello there today i have a special guest
uh dominic from germany who promotes the
german language uh he calls it get
germanized so we're gonna get germanized
and we're gonna find out a little bit
more about dominic hello good evening
dominic good evening good night uh yeah
my name is
very good
i mean i'm pretty sure you speak german
english deutsche
about this
all right all right all right so well my
name is dominic haneycom um i come from
germany as steve has mentioned from the
state of lower saxony or nida zachsen
and i have been on youtube making videos
about the german language or learning
languages and german culture since
basically 2006
professionally i've started it in 2013
after
doing my bachelor's thesis at university
i noticed this could become
well more than just a hobby and i've
always been passionate about helping
people
learning and
well empowering people to better
themselves in in any way possible so
that's what i'm trying to do with my
channel
and to
make it a little bit entertaining as
well because language i mean for some
people it looks very
um
well scary sometimes because of the
difficult grammar and all the processes
that are involved with learning a new
language and i just want to take away
that fear a little bit and make it fun
if possible
i i told steve this before i
don't see myself necessarily as
a grammar teacher or something like that
that can really go in depth but a
facilitator of language that keeps or
that gets people motivated to learn it
and keeps them interested in it
hopefully at least you know it's
interesting when it comes to grammar and
some people think of german you know
separated verbs and
did them be
whatever and they get intimidated
certainly that was my experience it was
only when i stopped doing it that i
could learn the language
but uh if a person is motivated you know
i i always think we had a dog when our
kids were young
and if he was chasing whatever a cat
like he would go through the
bramble bush he'd come out the other
side bleeding it didn't matter he wanted
to get that cat you know and if you can
motivate people
to learn german or chinese people will
learn the characters in chinese people
will learn the grammar in german if
they're motivated so i think you're on
the right track if you can motivate
people they'll deal with these other
issues now one other thing so we're
talking motivation so i know a lot of
people are motivated by german rock
music music ramstein and so forth i'm
not a tomboy yes that way zero zero i
wouldn't know rammerstein from uh
rumplestiltskin but
when you say lower saxony then i think
of
i don't know where that is except that
is that
near leipzig is that near bach country
is that what has it anything to do is
that sort of north of uh bohemia of the
czech republic uh where tell us where
laura saxony is
laura saxony is in the north of germany
leipzig is about
five hours
from where i love actually i'm going
there this friday because i was about to
go to the leipzig book fair
which was cancelled because of the
corona scare at the moment
but i'm still just gonna go there and to
explore the city but yeah uh in the
north of germany um the capital city
here is hanover actually you might have
heard of hello like i always look at a
map you know germany north south uh
north is upper and uh and uh but in fact
the reverse so i guess it's lower saxony
is north of saxony uh you know
dresden
okay
uh now how what so i mean i'm an old
fatty daddy so i'm more into older
things don't say that all the things
and to me i i can tell you what what i
found attractive uh
with german and the whole german
experience including my travels there
but let me ask you what are the the
kinds of things either that
have motivated people to learn german or
that you use to motivate people to learn
german
well um i have asked this question
actually um a couple of times
and my viewers have said so far that
many of them have been influenced as you
uh
said by ramstein by music um because
ramstein is internationally uh famous
and popular and so i understand and it's
kind of funny because the first thing
some people will write is like dude
you have like the song by ramstein or
some other lyrics and i believe the band
the german band tokyo hotel is
internationally famous as well and they
were for a time at least uh getting
people to learn german which i think is
fantastic like to me it doesn't really
matter what motivates someone to learn
the language as long as they have
something that interests them because i
strongly believe that if you
don't learn about something in the
language that really interests you then
it is very much harder to
keep yourself motivated and stay
learning
and other than that definitely german tv
shows
people always tell me how they like
what was it dark this new netflix
mystery
show and people just started learning or
getting interested in the german culture
because of shows like this can we stop
for a second very interesting next oh
yeah sure netflix okay netflix is a
major source of language learning
content
um oh for sure i used it for turkish for
a while
uh i even found an arabic uh series
there but it was in egyptian arabic and
i couldn't understand a word
but so there are a lot of german series
on netflix
and i think there's even a thing called
learning languages with netflix where
you can go through frame by frame and
and look at the subtitles say in german
and oh really yeah i didn't know that
you import
we we can bring netflix movies into link
and i did that and i brought you can
also import the dialogue as a lesson
so netflix is part of this whole world
of content that's out there and if i
were learning german i'd be all over
netflix um absolutely although
what is your opinion how good can you
start with netflix or do you have to
ramp up to where you can make use of
netflix or tv series as a learning
material well
well i mean
difficult to say because i am i don't i
just speak english in german fluently so
it's hard for me but um
when i learned english i motivated
myself also with tv shows or actually to
be precise uh japanese animation and it
had english subtitles all the time and
every time
i wanted to know a story plot or what
was going on and i didn't know a word in
the subtitles i just looked it up at a
dictionary or something like that so i
believe if people have like a basic
understanding at least
then
learning vocabulary with stuff like this
with netflix and movies is very
good at least for me it was um but but i
believe there should be
a little bit of a basis maybe otherwise
you don't understand anything but what
do you think about that i'm curious yeah
if i take my experience with russian for
example
uh fairly early in my russian learning i
uh i found a bookstore in vancouver
where they sold you know
russian movie dvds
so i bought some of these but it was
more stimulus because like you know here
wow look at me i'm watching a russian
and this is especially the old soviet
movies that were better than the more
recent russian movies and you know
something from the 19th century and
i found this stuff very motivating but i
couldn't use it as learning material
because i didn't underst i couldn't read
the russian script i could read the
english subtitles and then enjoy the
movie but it wasn't a language learning
experience so i i do believe you have to
get to a sort of an intermediate level
however you know
depends i mean if if you're going you
know english to french or english to
german there there's 30 40 of the words
there that you can recognize
so it may be easier but with russian i
found that i i had to ramp up with other
learning activities and then i could
start enjoying movies but it certainly
is motivating there's no question it's
mo it's the romance it's the romance of
germany so let's talk a bit about the
romance of germany so okay we've got
truck music we got netflix
how about what are some of the other
reasons why people learn german
um yeah talking about romance well for
romance for love
many people these days get to know their
their special someone through the
internet and it's becoming more and more
normal i think it is pretty normal by
now and um that way uh
this
well getting to know people from other
countries has become very easy uh
because of the internet and so many
people have found someone and want to
learn their language as a for example
germany or german in this case and they
come here they live here and learn the
language basically and the motivation is
their partner which makes a lot of sense
because that is one of the greatest
motivations i believe that you can have
to learn a language for someone you love
can i go the other way i want to learn
this language so i'll go and find a an
emotional romantic partner then when i
lose oh yeah language i'll go find
another partner for the new language
that i'm learning i don't know
actually now that you are saying that i
won't name any names but i think you
might know this person as well i have
met um another polyglot
at
uh at a language um event in berlin last
year and he told me actually that
he does that sometimes he keeps around
people
that speak certain languages basically
flatmates and i guess maybe girlfriends
as well i'm not 100 sure but that was
super interesting to me like i was
always wondering how how do polyglots
that speak a lot of languages keep the
language fresh and i guess that is one
of the ways you can do it so yeah i i
mean i think a because i i happen to be
happily married that um
the option of going out and finding
girlfriends in each of my languages is
not an option
and with 20 languages you can't
constantly be looking for people who
speak those languages so it ends up
being more a matter of refreshing them
occasionally through lots of listening
and reading and
those kinds of things
uh i also wanted to say that uh you know
germany uh
a little bit about my experience with
german
and germany is a wonderful place to
visit
and you sometimes hear people say well i
went to germany and i spoke in german
and they answered in english and it's
very discouraging and stuff and that
might be
in a department store in berlin or in
hamburg or in uh you know munich
but
one of the more
i mean charming places to visit in
germany is the small towns
and you stay in a small wind and it's i
don't know what it is now but it used to
be very cheap
the meals were cheap and very cozy yeah
i i guess depends on where but yeah yeah
cheaper definitely you stay in these
towns that are just like like they're so
beautiful like they're
postcard perfect little towns and i can
remember i stayed many times i had
business dealings not too far from
lincols
uh if you i think it's brutal yeah i
mean it's a romantic town and there and
there the people don't speak so much
english and so there's no difficulty in
speaking german and so you're kind of
able to put yourself into this german
medieval german town and speak german
and there's even little bookstores there
and so i think there's ample opportunity
and
people in germany are very friendly
there's sometimes this thing that the
germans are very strict and severe
okay so people are actually very
friendly and if you're driving around in
the gas stations and in the inns and
stuff so it's it's uh it's a very
pleasant place to visit and if you want
to use your german in my opinion be a
little strategic don't go into places
where people are busy
and uh they hear you stumble in german
they're gonna answer in english because
but if you go to the smaller towns you
can have a very nice romantic german
experience at least that's been my
experience
well i'm really happy that you think
that that's wonderful
i mean i always hope that people have a
good time coming here and when when they
say that
oh they only speak to me in english
because they they want to help me i also
understand that i guess but many germans
also are very keen on just practicing
their english as you say as you said in
bigger cities and when it's a hectic
situation it's just faster for them than
help the other person necessarily but
also yes in smaller villages or towns
you will have all the opportunity you
want even though the younger folk there
will speak english as well so if you
want to switch to english that's most of
the time no problem right
i i feel at least yeah and besides which
those people if you meet a german person
as a young person in a small town
they found someone to speak to in
english
so yeah they want to speak english so
why does your
right to speak german trump their right
to speak english you know neither one of
you is a teacher so you got to work
those things out
um that's one other one thing i'm
curious about too is like what are some
of the so what is some of the messaging
uh that you give your followers either
when it comes to
uh why they should uh learn german or
about how better to learn german and
what are some of the tricks about
dealing with german and you know the
long convoluted
sentences with long phrases and relative
clauses and
separated verbs and what sort of advice
do you give them
well first of all i guess um why they
should learn german or why they should
learn any second language is just
because it makes you a lot more
empathetic how do you say
yeah empathetic um towards other
cultures and it gives you so many
opportunities if you learn another
language you i mean that's why i learned
english because i didn't just want to be
confined to my own country to the
possibilities within my own country i
wouldn't be doing what i'm doing right
now if i didn't learn a second language
and i traveled and felt comfortable in
other countries because i knew english
because
yeah i don't know it's just super
helpful in so many areas of your life
and
well when it comes to tips on how i can
just even better there so that's english
but no it's just an international
language you know so what's the what's
the
motivation for learning german which
really only works in you know this this
germany austria switzerland
area
well um there's many job opportunities
for people who want to become for
example engineers as stereotypical as
that is it is true um or just in other
uh areas of uh of jobs you can of course
use german as well here or if um
hmm well that is a difficult question to
answer now that i'm thinking about it
but i think that is definitely one of
the areas that helps i mean uh
there are lots of places where german is
is a very important language certainly
navy yeah it's not just true poland
you know croatia italy even france it's
a it's a major european language so i
didn't want to be facetious right yeah
no it's fine
um well and it always depends on the
person maybe they have ancestors from
germany and that's uh they're interested
in their culture and maybe they won't
want to visit one day and then of course
you can get along with just speaking
english but speaking german
will come across as being interested in
the culture and the people and just as
polite as well in a way we don't
necessarily it makes for such a much
more pleasant experience visiting when
you can oh yeah read the newspaper you
turn on the tv hopefully you don't turn
on cnn you turn on german tv you get
this whole feeling of being in the
country so yeah absolutely true i
definitely agree that's why actually you
motivated me to pick up learning
japanese again because
they studied it a tiny bit at university
but just your mere existence that you
know so many languages i felt very
inadequate and so i started learning
japanese again you're young and okay
so what do you how do you deal with the
difficulties of the german people
perceive
german as having long convoluted uh you
know
sentences separated verbs case endings
how do you deal with these issues what
do you tell people
well i mean most of the really scary
words that they see for example this
donor damshir that's gift capitaine this
really long one most of those they never
get used in actual german everyday
language and so people don't need to be
scared um
for example when people are scared of
daddy dust i always tell them or just
learn the articles with the word that
makes it a lot easier and
i don't know there's
i think people make it out
scarier to be scarier than it actually
is in my mind sometimes
many tell me that once they start
learning the language they they see
patterns and they see that it's well not
as hard as i thought so yeah i agree 100
and you know the people scary say well
german is a
subject
object verbling svo and other languages
sov like people the brain figures that
out very quickly
uh even the lengthy can be lengthy lots
of you know subordinate clause type
sentences the brain gets used to it the
brain will get used to it with enough
listening and reading without lengthy
complicated explanations it you start to
get used to this pattern and in fact i
find it very enjoyable as with every
language so i think the secret there as
you say is as to kind of summarize if
you are motivated enough to expose
yourself enough to the language the
brain is going to start noticing these
patterns a little bit of explanation
might help but ultimately the brain will
kind of sort things out that's been my
experience
oh i agree definitely so um yeah and
advice for all your viewers don't be
scared just start learning and you will
see that it's not as scary okay
thank you so you're a motivator so i'll
go to you i'll leave a link to your
youtube channel
thank you and uh you know get people
motivated and you provide you know hints
to them on how to overcome any
difficulties they have in german and
hopefully we will increase the number of
people learning german so thank you very
much let's hope so
thank you for having me thank you so
much thank you dominic bye thank you bye
cheers
[Music]
you